[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la catalogne qui nous a occupé une bonne
partie de l'année 2010 cette voie très
certainement rester encore très présente
sur nos écrans radars en 2018 puisque
dans les faits rien n'a été réglé par
les multiples échéances électorales de
2010 est le référendum bien sûr les
élections aussi convoqué par le
gouvernement central de madrid dans les
faits le bras de fer va sans doute se
poursuivre encore longtemps
entre deux hommes que tout semble
opposer mariano rajoy le chef du
gouvernement espagnol qui lui a une
vision très très légaliste des choses
une vision je dirais
constitutionnalistes qui considère donc
que la constitution ne permet pas une
cession d'une partie de l'espagne est
donc tout vote sur la question est
totalement impossible de l'autre côté
carlos putsch damon donc parle d'un
grand principe celui du droit des
peuples à décider de leur destinée dans
les faits donc le problème reste entier
il va continuer nous occuper
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'année 2010 est en france bien
évidemment a été marquée par l'arrivée
au pouvoir des manuels macron un homme
qui à l'époque n'avaient pas 40 ans
issus de nulle part qui a donc fondé son
propre parti c'était du jamais vu en
france c'est un réformateur
il s'est attaqué d'emblée à un dossier
très ambitieux celui de la réforme du
code du travail
avant lui nicolas sarkozy françois
hollande s'était cassé les dents sur ce
dossier là il semble en voie d'y
parvenir mais il ne veut pas s'arrêter
en si bon chemin en 2018 il veut
s'attaquer à la réforme des retraites un
dossier épineux pour beaucoup qui risque
d'amener peut-être à des manifestations
encore mais il a de l'ambition emmanuel
macron et se voit une destinée
européenne il veut profiter de la
faiblesse par exemple dongala merkel en
allemagne de terry âmes est empêtré dans
le bric site en angleterre il se voit
donc une destinée européenne et pourquoi
pas mondial
en 2018 on va bien évidemment suivre le
processus du brésil qui se poursuit une
première vague de négociation a déjà
permis d'écarter les premiers écueils
mais beaucoup de points épineux reste à
régler c'est important parce qu'à terme
ça va complètement changer la face de
l'europe les dynamiques ou aussi entre
les différents pays non seulement au
sein même de l'europe mais aussi
ailleurs dans le monde parce que la
grande bretagne va devoir tisser des
liens des liens d'affaires des liens
politiques avec d'autres pays entre
autres le canada ça va je n'ai pas bien
évidemment sur toute la planète